a lot of what geometry is about is
proving things about the world in order
to really prove things about the world
we have to be very careful very precise
very exact with our language so that we
know what we're proving and we know what
we're assuming and and what type of
deductions we are making as we prove
things and so to get some practice being
precise and exact with our language I'm
going to go through some exercises from
the geometric the geometric definitions
exercise on Khan Academy so this first
one says three students attempt to
define what it means four lines L and M
to be perpendicular can you match the
teachers comments to the definitions all
right so it looks like three different
students attempt definitions of what it
means to be perpendicular and then
there's these teachers comments that we
can move around so we're gonna I guess
pretend that we're the teacher so Ruby's
definition for being perpendicular L and
M lines L and M are perpendicular if
they never meet well that's not true in
fact perpendicular lines for sure will
intersect so the fact they intersect at
right angles so that is not going to be
that's not going to be correct and so
actually this looks right were you
thinking of parallel lines because that
looks like what she was trying to trying
to define if things are on the same
plane and they never intersect
then you are talking about parallel
lines I also get shriya's definition L
and M are perpendicular if they meet at
one point and one of the angles at their
point of intersection is a right angle
well that seems spot-on so let's see I
would say ooh nice work I couldn't have
said it better myself now let's just
make sure this with this comment matches
for this definition
Abhishek says L and M are perpendicular
if they meet at a single point such that
the two lines make a tea well that's in
a hand wavy way kind of right when you
when you imagine a perpendicular lines
you could imagine them kind of forming a
cross or I guess part of you know a tea
would be part of it
but I think this comment is spot-on the
teachers comment your definition is kind
of correct but it lacks mathematical
precision you know what are they what
does he mean by a T what is a that what
does it mean to make a T frias
definition is much more precise so
perpendicular if they meet at one point
and one of their angles at their point
of intersection is a right angle is a 90
degree angle
let's check our answer so let's do a few
more of these this is actually a lot of
fun so once again we're gonna have three
students attempting to define but now
they're going to define an object called
an angle can you match the teachers
comments to the definitions so Ruby of
these three same three students Ruby
says the amount of turn between two
straight lines that have a common vertex
well this is kind of getting there the
definition of an angle we typically talk
about two rays with a common vertex
she's talking about two lines with a
common vertex and she's talking about
the amount of turns so she's really
talking about more of kind of the
measure of an angle so let's see what
what comment here so you seem to be
getting at the idea of a measure of an
angle and not the definition of an angle
itself so this is actually right I would
put this one right here we just got
lucky this this was already aligned so
shriya's definition two lines that come
together so once again this is kind of
the definition of an angle is two raised
with a common vertex so two lines that
come together this is just intersecting
lines I want that happens you might be
forming some angles but I would just say
were you thinking of intersecting lines
and let's see what Abby Shaikh says a
figure composed of two rays sharing a
common endpoint the common endpoint is
known as the vertex yep that's that's a
good definition of an angle so Abby she
ate God at this time let's do another
one
so three students are now attempting to
define what it means for two lines to be
parallel so now let's match the teachers
comments so Daniella says two lines are
parallel if they are distinct and one
can be translated on top of the other
all right so that actually seems pretty
interesting
that's actually not the first way that I
would have defined parallel line notice
today if they're on the same plane and
they don't intersect then they are
parallel but this is this seems pretty
good because if you're translating
something you're not you're not you you
aren't going to rotate it you're not
going to change its direction I guess
one way to think about it and so if
you're translating one if you can Tran
if there if there are two different
lines but you can you can shift them
without changing their direction which
is what translation is all about on top
of each other that actually feels pretty
good so I'll put that right over there
so Ori says two lines are parallel if
they are close together but don't
intersect so if you're trying to define
parallel lines parallel lines it doesn't
matter if they're close together or not
it's they just have to be in the same
plane and not intersect they could be
very far apart and they could still be
parallel so this isn't an incorrect
statement you could have two lines that
are close together and don't intersect
on the same plane and they are going to
be parallel but this isn't a good
definition because you can also have
parallel lines that are far apart and so
actually I'd go at the statement right
here part of your definition is correct
but the other part is not parallel lines
don't have to be close together so this
isn't a good definition of parallel
lines and let's see Kaori two lines are
parallel as long as they aren't
perpendicular well that's just not true
because you can intersect you can have
two lines that intersect at non right
angles and they're not parallel and
they're also not perpendicular so this
is you know sorry your definition is
incorrect this is actually a lot of fun
pretending to be the teacher let's do
another one all right so three students
attempt to define what a line segment is
and we have a depiction of a line
segment right over here it's we have
point P point Q and the line segment is
all the points in between P and Q so so
let's let's match the teachers comments
to the definitions Ivy's definition all
of the points in line with P and Q
extending infinitely in both directions
well that would be the definition of a
line that would be the line PQ that
would be if you're extending
in both directions so I would say are
you thinking of a line instead of a line
segment
Ethan's definition the exact distance
from P to Q well that's just a that's
just the the that's the length of a line
segment
that's not exactly what a line segment
is let's see if buca's definition the
points P and Q which are called
endpoints and all of the points in a
straight line between points P and Q yep
that looks like a good definition for a
line segment and so we can just check R
we can just check our answer
so looking good let's do one more of
this I'm just really enjoying pretending
to be a teacher all right three students
attempted to find what a circle is
define what a circle is can you match
the teachers comments to the definitions
Daru the set of all points in a plane
that are the same distance away from
some given point which we call the
center that actually seems like a pretty
good definition of a circle so
stupendous well done Oliver's Devon
Oliver's definition the set of all
points in 3d space that are the same
distance from a Centerpoint well for
talked about 3d space and the set of all
points that are equidistant from that
point in 3d space now we're talking
about a sphere not a circle and so you
seem to be confusing a circle with this
year and then finally a perfectly round
shape well that's kind of true but if
you don't want three dimensions you
could be talking about a sphere if you
talk about you know if you go beyond
three dimensions hyper sphere or
whatever else in two dimensions yeah a
perfectly round shape most people would
call it a circle but that doesn't have a
lot of precision to it it doesn't have
it doesn't give us a lot that we can
work with from a mathematical point of
view so I would say actually what the
teacher saying your definition needs to
be much more precise Durer's definition
is is is much much more precise the set
of all points that are equidistant from
that in a plane that are equidistant
away from a given point which we call
the center so yeah Carlos could use a
little bit more precision and we're all
done